[Musique]
on
bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de mode d'emploi
votre magazine consacré à l'emploi et
aux formations focus ce mois ci sur la
reconversion professionnelle tout de
suite le sommaire elles ont décidé ou
été contrainte de changer de métier en
passant par une reconversion
professionnelle
lauriane et éducatrice canin depuis
septembre 2018 lydia fait une formation
pour devenir secrétaire assistante nous
les avons rencontrés pour découvrir leur
parcours s'adresser aux bons acteurs
choisir sa nouvelle activité et utiliser
les dispositifs existants nous recevons
pauline luciani pincer lee directrice
territoriale délégué de pôle emploi dans
les yvelines
elle vous donnera les clés pour réussir
sa reconversion enfin rendez vous de
l'emploi à noter dans vos agendas qui
concerne une formation dans le domaine
du numérique elle a décidé de se
reconvertir après avoir travaillé
quelques années dans une salle une
agence de communication lauriane primo
li est devenue éducatrice et
comportementaliste canin à guyancourt
une activité qu'elle a commencé à
exercer en septembre dernier après avoir
effectué une reconversion
professionnelle
rencontre avec cette saint-quentinoise
des images sont signés michael et demi
d'euros on est content on est content
lauriane primes liées et éducatrices et
comportementaliste pour chiens c'est sa
quatrième séance avec olea berger
australien de dix mois
le problème de cette chaîne l'obéissance
de base olea c'est bien fifi c'est bien
au pied c'est bien très bien
c'est une chaîne qui saute beaucoup d
calé dès qu'elle est malade et qu'elle a
envie de jouer dès qu'elle est contente
elle voilà c'est comme ça qu'est elle a
du mal à canaliser son énergie
l'objectif c'est dû montrer qu'il ya des
temps de jeu mais aussi des temps voilà
où faut écouter a 32 ans cette grille en
courtoise a créé sa micro entreprise en
septembre 2010 huit conseils d'éducation
pour chiens compréhension du
comportement avec des exercices pour
faire comprendre l'obéissance à l'animal
souvent l'erreur qui est comme et c'est
quand on a un chiot on l'y autorise tout
parce qu'il est petit
sauf que il ne faut pas oublier qu'un
chiot s'agrandit et que bah quand il est
gros plus il a été habitué à certaines
choses
et après le retour en arrière est plus
difficile donc vaut mieux habitués à un
show tout de suite à certaines règles
que plus tard que je pense qu'en
fonction du caractère du chien en
fonction de la race on doit adapter
aussi certaines certaines choses moi moi
même je n'applique pas toujours la même
chose forcément en fonction des chiens
j'ai toujours une base mais ces
variables ces techniques lauriane les a
apprises lors de sa reconversion
professionnelle un changement de voie et
un changement de vie choisi le métier
que je fais enfin en fait nous permet
vraiment de compléter et mon métier
d'éducateur canin et de m'occuper comme
nous de mes enfants qui va qui sont
encore très petit et ça me permet pour
être partagé beaucoup ma vie avec eux et
partager beaucoup de moments c'est des
fiches comme ça et je m'amuse et en fait
à reproduire ces fiches là après à les
résumés dans mon classeur les animaux
c'est une passion depuis son plus jeune
âge après le bac et deux ans de faculté
de droit
lauriane primo lire entre en école de
commerce après avoir obtenu son diplôme
elle intègre une agence de relations
presse basée à puteaux vraiment j'ai été
contente mais sans plus voilà j'étais
c'est pas à cause de faire un pas
forcément à cause de l'argent ce pas
forcément à cause du boulot en lui-même
c'était vraiment juste je me suis dit je
ne vois pas faire ça toute ma vie j'ai
besoin de voir autre chose de bouger de
d'être plus bas à confronter à
l'internet à la nature chose que je
voulais faire et en plus jeunes avant
même que j'attaque tout mais grande
étude
ce côté-là communication marketing m'a
toujours intéressé et encore même
aujourd'hui 1 c'est à dire que ça ne
sert de base pour créer mon site
internet pour nous occuper des réseaux
sociaux de ma société
après avoir obtenu des renseignements
pour engager sa reconversion
elles financent sa formation a good and
park pour devenir éducateur canin et
comportementaliste des compétences
acquises entre le mois d'août 2010 est
et juin 2018 avec la possibilité de
s'occuper de ses enfants qu une partie
théorique qui se fait à la maison et
après a un côté pratique donc une
formation pratique où on va dans le jura
et il y a
et on bosse en fait les acquis depuis le
lancement de sa micro-entreprise
l'éducatrice canin guyancourt toise a
signé six contrats de clients soit entre
6 et 8 rendez vous par semaine sur notre
plateau pauline luciani pinzelli nous a
rejoint bonsoir alors vous êtes
directrice territoriale délégué de pôle
emploi dans les yvelines on vient de
voir un exemple de reconversion
professionnelle je rappelle son parcours
elle a fait une école de commerce a
travaillé quelques années dans une
agence agence de communication avant de
changer d'activité mais très rapidement
finalement votre regard sur ce parcours
disons que ce que laurianne son parcours
est tout à fait représentatif d'une
tendance très lourde du marché du
travail qui est con on est probablement
amenés à ne pas exercer le même métier
tout au long de sa vie
donc aujourd'hui il ya des études qui
montrent qu'en moyenne on va changé cinq
fois de d'emplois dans une vie
professionnelle
donc je trouve ça voilà très
représentatif
ce qui est assez frappant aussi c'est
kelly a pensé dès son précédent métier
et qu'on sent que c'est un projet
qu'elle a mûri qu'elle a travaillée et
qu'elle a placé dans le temps avec avec
son congé maternité
donc on sent quelque chose de très
travaillé et d'aujourd'hui traits
portraits réussis manifestement les
personnes qui se tournent vers une
reconversion professionnelle quels sont
les facteurs qui les poussent à passer
via ce type de deux changements alors il
ya 2 il ya deux grands motifs
il ya un premier motif très simple et
très fréquent qui est peut-être
l'impossibilité pour des raisons
personnelles de ou circonstancielle
d'exercer le dernier métier qu'on a
qu'on a réalisé donc une nécessité de
trouver un autre métier et d'ailleurs je
rappelle que à ce titre en fait 40 % des
personnes inscrites à pôle emploi par
exemple retrouve dans un métier autre
que celui qu'ils 1 qui sont exercées et
précédemment donc c'est effectivement
quelque chose d'assez fréquents et c'est
une première raison et puis la deuxième
raison c'est une effectivement une
inspiration personnelle qui peut qui
peut se faire jour notamment ici l'envoi
aussi le désir d'être là son compte qui
est aussi une tendance une tendance
forte en fait en matière de reconversion
professionnelle dont quitté le salariat
pour être à son compte
alors si des salariés nous regardent ou
si même des demandeurs d'emploi nous
regarde
quelles démarches doivent-ils engagée
s'ils veulent se reconvertir
alors la reconversion professionnelle
tout est dans la préparation parce
qu'effectivement c'est avant tout un
projet sur lequel il faut d'abord
s'interroger soi-même sur sur le désir
qu'on a de se reconvertir étudié
vraiment à la fois les compétences
nécessaires pour le métier puis les
savoir-être et le cadre requis pour
exercer ce nouveau métier donc il ya une
toute une préparation sur lequel on peut
être accompagnés et puis souvent
effectivement ça passe par une halle
entre par l'entrée en formation ce qu'on
appelle la formation professionnelle
continue au delà de sa formation
des informations initiales et là il faut
se poser à la fois la question du
financement de cette formation et de la
rémunération de cette formation
ici on voit une formation qui a duré
plusieurs mois il s'agit à la fois de la
finance et et puis de continuer
peut-être avoir un revenu de
remplacement
donc c'est un ce sont des dispositifs
qu'il faut étudier alors pauline les
ziani pinzelli rester avec nous je vous
propose maintenant de découvrir un autre
parcours celui de lydia portier elle est
actuellement reconversion
professionnelle après avoir été reconnus
travailleurs handicapés
nous avons rencontré cette habitante de
trappes dans le centre de rééducation
professionnelle auxilia de nanterre où
elle suit sa formation regardé et je
vous fait réagir juste après techniques
de dressage un lecture de pointe salle
des préparations culinaires et de la
technique de mémorisation ses
compétences lydia portier les utiliser
dans son métier de serveuse dans la
restauration
après plus de vingt ans de carrière dans
ce secteur d'activité elle a été
contrainte d'effectuer une reconversion
professionnelle
tout a commencé par un accident du
travail ensuite
ben le médecin du travail qui vous dit
que vous êtes inapte dans votre métier
déjà ça commence par un deuil pas
parrainer sens mais par un deuil
le day 2
plus pouvoir faire le métier qu'on a
toujours fait depuis plus de 20 ans on
commence par ça c'est d'admettre que ton
métier d'avancé terminé tu pourras plus
et là c'est une renaissance après avoir
été conseillé par pôle emploi et cap
emploi la renaissance de lydia portier
commence en septembre 2018
à travers une formation de 17 mois au
centre de rééducation professionnelle
auxilia de nanterre pour devenir
secrétaire assistante les personnes sont
reconversion pour raisons de santé
donc déjà sur toutes les formations il
ya un module préparatoire qui dure trois
ou quatre mois c'est de la remise à
niveau un travail sur le projet et puis
c'est une remise en route parce que
souvent les personnes sont en arrêt
maladie depuis un bon moment
on a plusieurs modules donc le premier
module qui est constitué de tout ce qui
est gestion de planning de réunion tout
ce qui est administratif bureautique et
le deuxième module qui est plus axé sur
la gestion commerciale et les ressources
humaines
120 stagiaires sont actuellement en
formation au crb auxilia de nanterre le
centre de rééducation professionnelle le
plus proche pour les travailleurs
handicapés des yvelines alors là on le
voit c'est une reconversion
professionnelle mais contrainte à cause
de sa reconnaissance en tant que
travailleur handicapé ce que c'est des
situations que vous rencontrez
fréquemment
oui bien sûr parce que voilà les
accidents du travail ça arrive des
accidents aussi de la vidéo ça arrive
après ça peut être aussi des
déménagements qui font qu'on sort d'une
zone où on avait l'habitude d'exercer
son emploi donc oui c'est assez fréquent
comment on les accompagne ces personnes
est ce qu'il ya un accompagnement
particulier de la part de pôle emploi
oui alors nous nous avons dans chaque
agence pour l'emploi des conseillers en
évolution professionnelle est également
des psychologues du travail qui peuvent
aider à faire tout le travail de
préparation qui a été très bien évoqué
ici d'abord à la fois de prise de
conscience de la nécessité de changer
et puis et puis d'accompagnement sur le
projet notamment en identifiant voilà
les compétences et les
les formations en fait à acquérir pour
pour exercer son futur métier alors
polynesian 15 lits on voit à l'image les
conseils pour se recontrent pour se
reconvertir lancer sa reconversion il
dagenais d'abord il faut réfléchir à son
projet pour le mûrir en fait c'est se
poser les bonnes questions en passant
par des enquêtes métier qu'est ce que
c'est a précisé ce que si une enquête
une enquête métier c'est tout simplement
d'aller re d'aller à la rencontre de
potentiels recruteurs
voilà on peut aller jusqu'à même à pôle
emploi on propose les immersions
professionnels qui sont des espèces de
mini stage dans une entreprise pourra se
tester ce que je recommande également
c'est une un
une application que dont chaque
demandeur d'emploi dispose dans son
espace personnel qui s'appelle mon
potentiel professionnel et qui permet
d'aller explorer d'autres métiers à
partir des compétences qu'on a déjà
acquise
on peut ainsi repérer également les
entreprises qui recrutent dans son
bassin et en changeant de métier et
c'est là la deuxième phase c'est-à-dire
identifier les compétences à acquérir
pour sa nouvelle activité et sa future
activité ce qui vous amène à rechercher
une formation que vous pouvez financer
notamment avec le compte personnel de
formation
enfin il faut prévoir finalement les
implications sur de la reconversion
professionnelle sur la vie privée parce
que des fois il peut y avoir moins de
revenus faut s'assurer que on puisse
continuer à vivre avec
avec les revenus que con ac et qu'on
acquiert avec la re notamment un stand
la location quand on est en demande
quand on est demandeur d'emploi
finalement ça n'est ce pas de
rémunérations il est essentiel il faut
pas négliger dans la préparation de son
projet est alors pour toutes ces
démarches
vous pouvez notamment vous rendre donc
dans les agences pôle emploi de saint
quentin en yvelines ou à la cité des
métiers de saint quentin en yvelines
pauline luciani pinzelli merci d'être
venu sur le plateau avant de conclure
cette émission si vous souhaitez suivre
une formation de développeurs web ou
développeur data simplon qu ouvrir une
école elancourt une formation du 26
décembre à fin juin 2019 pour des
emplois dans le secteur du numérique
vous voyez la date s'afficher en bas de
l'écran vous pouvez candidate et
jusqu'au 15 décembre 2018
l'information est aussi en bas de
l'écran inscriptions et informations sur
le site internet c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivis
rendez-vous le mois prochain pour un
nouveau numéro d'ici là à bientôt sur tv
[Musique]